[APPLAUSE]
LINDA ROTTENBERG: Hello.
It is great to be
back at Google.
I met Larry Page and
Sergey Brin in 1999.
We were actually all part
of a world economic forum
group called The Global
Leaders for Tomorrow.
And there were about
50 of us a year
from different industries
and different countries.
And most of us had actually
been using Google Search before.
So none of us were
particularly surprised
by the trajectory
of Larry and Sergey.
But I vividly remember
early on the two
of them sitting down with this
very animated Chinese guy who'd
been this English teacher and
had set up the Yellow Pages--
the online Yellow
Pages of China.
And he had this idea for
this big marketplace.
It seemed quite
improbable to most people.
And in fact, he was
known as Crazy Jack.
And I'm sure many
of you are guessing
that this is Jack Ma who
just took Alibaba public.
So yet another example of
why crazy is a complement.
I want to step back
and share a little bit
about how I got here.
So I grew up outside of Boston
in a traditional family.
My parents met as high school
sweethearts in Rhode Island.
My dad went on to be a lawyer.
My mom stayed at home
to raise three kids.
And they are very loving,
very focused on education,
and inherently risk averse.
So some of this
rubbed off on me.
I went to Harvard for college.
I went to Yale for law
school, got to law school
and figured I had no
interest in practicing law.
So I found out about
this opportunity
to go to Latin America
after law school.
My parents assumed it was a one
year Peace Corps type thing.
And I started in Chile and
Uraguay, landed in Argentina,
and just fell in love
with the culture,
learned tango, and rooted
for local soccer teams.
But something started
happening, which
is that now it was the mid
'90s and everyone at home
was talking about
Yahoo and Netscape,
and this entrepreneurial
revolution I was going on.
And in Latin America, all
the young people I met
were aspiring to
government jobs.
And this was very
confusing to me.
And my aha moment
came when I was late
for a meeting in Buenos
Aires and got into a taxi,
and learned that my driver
had an engineering degree.
So I asked what I thought
was a logical question, which
is excuse me, but what are
you doing driving a cab.
And he proceeded to say that
the governments weren't hiring
and all the old school companies
didn't have any use for someone
with his skills.
And I tried to ask
why it was that he
wasn't starting a new company,
becoming an entrepreneur.
And I realized I didn't
know the word in Spanish
for entrepreneur.
And though it's hard
to believe today,
20 years ago, there was
no word actively used
in Spanish or Portuguese
or Turkish or Arabic
for entrepreneur.
Now, I say this so that the
blogosphere won't get mad at me
and say oh, you gringa,
you don't know emprendedor,
empreendedorismo exists.
In fact, I will scroll
and then go backwards,
but five years into
starting Endeavor,
we got a call from the editor
of the Portuguese-Brazilian
dictionary saying partly
because of Endeavor's work,
he was adding the
term emprendedor
and empreendedorismo
into the Lexicon.
So there is a word today,
but there really wasn't.
And this was this moment for
me when I said, wait a minute,
why isn't there an
organization to support
these dreamers, these
innovators in places
that don't support risk taking?
But to do this, I had to
take some risk myself.
And the first meeting of
Endeavor with my co-founder
Peter and myself took place
at my parents' kitchen table
in Newton.
And when my parents
overheard us plotting
this global organization,
they were not pleased.
My father came over
and reminded me
that I don't have a
trust fund and would need
to be financially independent.
If you don't want-- well, how
about consulting, he said.
When this wasn't
working, my mother
who's always been very
on-message about her desire
to have us produce
grandchildren came over
and suggested that maybe getting
on planes for all this time
wouldn't be the best
way to start a family.
And besides, she
said very nicely,
my eggs were not
getting any younger.
This month I
actually told my mom
that she was just ahead of her
time, because as most of you
know, Apple and
Facebook started--
for better or for worse--
these egg freezing programs.
But so my mother was
just ahead of the time.
But to me, this-- my
kitchen table moment,
as I call it-- was
really this moment
that I think that every
dreamer I know faces.
It's this tension between
doing what's safe and expected
and doing what's
unsafe and unknown.
It's this juncture
between fear and hope.
And I chose hope.
And I committed
myself in that moment
to help dreamers who
are feeling scared,
who are feeling stuck
in their moments
get unscared and unstuck.
So that really was the
origin of Endeavor.
Now, pretty soon after
that, Peter and I
had to find funding.
And no one thought
this was a good idea.
First of all, we were
starting in emerging markets.
We were finding
entrepreneurs, but we
were starting as a nonprofit to
support these very high growth
business innovators because
we felt there was money,
there was talent, there was
no trust in these markets.
So we wanted to
start out initially
just as a pure nonprofit.
And people thought
this would never work.
So I finally got a meeting
with an Argentine real estate
investor who would become the
one the largest landowners
and self-made entrepreneurs
in the country.
And it was a 10 minute meeting.
His name is Eduardo Elsztain.
And five minutes into our
meeting, he looks at his watch
and said I know, you
probably want a meeting
with George Soros, who
was his largest investor.
And I looked at him
and I said no, Eduardo.
I'm an entrepreneur.
You're an entrepreneur.
This organization is about
supporting entrepreneurs.
I want your time, your
passion, and $200,000.
So the meeting had been
taking place in English,
but at this point, he
turns to his right hand guy
and he says, esta
chica esta loca.
So I respond in Spanish
that I'm disappointed
that this from the man who
walked into Soros' office
and came out with a
$10 million check, he
was lucky I only asked
him for $200,000.
At that point, he turns away.
I had no idea what
he was going to do.
And he immediately
takes out a check
and writes me the $200,000.
And I always say that I
walked out of that meeting
with our first chairman of
Endeavor, Argentina, $200,000,
and my nickname la chica loca.
Which when we later moved to
the Middle East, carried over.
So just to tell you a little
bit-- you heard the numbers.
Endeavor now operates
in 22 countries.
We've screened 40,000
candidates, selected 1,000
to work with.
And as you heard, they generate
now over $7 billion annually
and they've created
400,000 jobs.
So I just want to stick with
Argentina for the moment
and tell two stories
just to encapsulate
what it is that we do.
One of the first-- so first of
all, we build in every country
we operate in, or every
city now that we've
expanded also to Miami
and are going to Detroit.
So we're in the United States
as well as Europe as well as
Africa, Asia, the Middle
East and Latin America.
And in every country, we form
a board of top business leaders
who will agree to put
their money, their time,
and their networks
to work to help find
these innovators in
every single industry,
in every walk of life
in their country.
And the requirement
is people who have
an idea that really can go big.
We are about that
scale-up moment.
At that point, we scour the
country, we build local teams.
Endeavor now has 350
people operating full time
around the world.
And we look for who
these dreamers might be.
We put them through
a year long process.
And one of the
first people we met
was this kid named
Wences Casares.
And I kept getting introduced
to him by people who said,
well, you're crazy.
We think he's crazy.
You two should meet.
He had grown up on a
sheep farm in Patagonia
and had the idea to create
the E-Trade of Latin America.
Now, he did not have
the right family
connections or last
name, but he was
determined to make this happen.
So much so that he
convinced his two sisters
to drop out of college
with him and had
to travel back to the
sheep farm in Patagonia
to tell his dad that
three kids were dropouts.
That beat my story.
34 investors had
turned him down.
He had almost nowhere to go.
But we saw this kernel of this
amazing entrepreneur in him.
So we put him
through the ringer.
We selected him as an
Endeavor entrepreneur.
And at that point, we
brought him on a road show.
We helped him raise $4 million
initially in venture capital,
including from Fred Wilson,
one of the top VCs in New York.
We helped him find a COO and
build a senior management team.
We recruited a Harvard MBA to
help him with a business plan.
And then later, Wences
married my assistant Belle.
Endeavor is a full
service organization.
18 months later, Wences
sold his company patagon.com
to Banco Santander
there $750 million.
I got 34 phone calls the next
day from those investors who
had turned him down
saying, did you find
any other entrepreneurs
in our country.
But here's what's really
important about the story,
it doesn't end there.
Wences has gone to found
five other companies.
He's now known for a
Bitcoin company called Xapo.
And he is one of the
most prolific mentors
and angel investors
on the continent,
even though he's now
living in Silicon Valley.
And four of the
people he mentored
were these four guys
in Buenos Aires who,
when the peso
devalued 66% in 2003,
said this is the best time
to start a software company.
And everyone said,
are you kidding me?
This is a disaster.
Why would anyone start a
software company from Argentina
now?
No one is going to buy this.
And they said no, you have
all this design talent
and we actually have a
cheaper labor force now.
But we can create really
high quality products.
They founded a company
called Globant.
They came through our process.
We actually rejected
them the first time
they came through our
selection process,
thinking they were too arrogant.
They came back
through the process,
become Endeavor entrepreneurs,
go on to get as their clients
Disney and Google and Nike.
They become one of the largest
job creators in the country.
And this August when
all of Argentina
was facing another debt crisis,
they took Globant public
on the New York Stock Exchange.
And now they're
creating universities
within universities to help
train people to get IT jobs.
And the last story
I'll tell, just
because it takes the cycle
forward and shows that we're
about all types
of entrepreneurs,
and one of the things I
feel is really important
to tell stories of
different types of people.
One of the four
founders of Globant
sat on one of the
selection panels
where he'd been rejected
10 years earlier.
And he was paired with
Steve Case of AOL.
And they were debating
on a number of companies.
And one of the
people they selected
was a woman named
Latifah Al-Waalan.
And Latifah grew
up in Saudi Arabia.
She got an MBA at the
University of Washington
and became immersed in
Seattle's coffee culture
and realized how frustrated
she'd been throughout her life
that her mother made
terrible spicy Arabic coffee.
And Latifah had tried to
recreate her grandmother's
delicious recipe and found
it incredibly complex
and time consuming.
It took 30 minutes
to make the coffee.
And Latifah thought,
oh my God, no
wonder so many Saudi women are
stuck for hours in the kitchen.
There must be a better way.
So she resolved to
create an automated
version of Arabic coffee, the
Nespresso of Arabic coffee.
She goes back to Riyadh.
First, she blends seven
spices and lightly roasted
beans into prepackaged,
premeasured packages.
She then works with
local engineers
and they manufacture
a machine that
reduces the time of
brewing the coffee by 75%.
So her grandmother's recipe goes
from 30 minutes down to seven.
And like every other
nay sayer, people
think this'll never work.
No one will ever buy it.
Now, most of the
naysayers were men.
And when they went back
to tell their wives,
the wives were
like, wait a minute.
Where can we get one of these?
And one wife said
to her husband,
you don't get it because
you don't spend time
in the kitchen.
I'll take those 23 extra
minutes, thank you.
And Latifah just became
an Endeavor entrepreneur.
She now sells her
manufactured Nespresso machine
through Whole Foods
and Williams Sonoma.
This year she'll
generate $10 million.
And what I love about
that story-- and now
we'll get to why I
wrote the book-- is
that I think we
need to freshen up
our image of the entrepreneur.
And one of the
things I've realized
working in so many
different environments
is that people hold
themselves back
in part because they feel like
they don't have an engineering
degree and don't live
in Silicon Valley.
So I kept saying you don't
need to be a boy in a hoodie
to be an entrepreneur.
And one of the things I do in
the book is share many stories
of Endeavor entrepreneurs and
non-Endeavor entrepreneurs--
people modern,
people historical,
people in every industry.
Because I feel like if we create
relatable and diverse role
models, people will say if he
can do it, if she can do it,
I can too.
But I had two other
reasons for finally sitting
down and writing a book.
I should say I'm married
to an author, Bruce Feiler.
He's written 12 New
York Times Best Sellers.
And I will say if any
of you are married
and you want empathy
for your spouse,
try doing what they do for a
living for a couple of years.
It changes your view on them.
And most entrepreneurship
books focus on the startup.
And what I've come to believe
is that entrepreneurship
is a journey that
starts there, but it
goes to the scale-up phase.
It's a journey of getting going,
going big, and going home.
Because I think that also it's
about how we marry our passions
and our work lives
with our family lives.
And so I really wanted
to write a book that
carried through the entire
arc of that journey.
So the sections of the book are
get going, go big, and go home.
But my last reason
for writing a book
is I started getting these
unexpected calls a couple years
ago, first from managers
of Fortune 500 companies
saying we are telling
our workers to be more
entrepreneurial and we think
we're being very clear,
but they're not
getting the message.
And the people inside
those companies
were telling me I'm terrified.
If I fail, I'm going to
lose my budget or my job.
Can you help me get these skills
to be more entrepreneurial
and get ahead at work
without risking my job?
And then parents at
drop-off at the school
where Jennifer and I
send our children started
coming and saying, you
know what, I've lost my job
and I'm in transition, and
I don't know whether to go
into another company.
Or I have this idea that I've
been looking at in my basement,
and I'm trying to figure
out if I can take it.
And what I realized
is that we all
need these entrepreneurial
skills today.
Entrepreneurship is not
just for the entrepreneurs
that are the high growth
companies as we know them.
Entrepreneurship
is for everyone.
Michael Dell told
me something that I
love and have to
repeat it, which
is that today, there are the
quick and there are the dead.
And to me, entrepreneurship
is for people
who want to get ahead
and take some risk.
But in fact, the
riskier strategy
is to do nothing at all.
So that was what
I set out to do.
And the first thing I realized
is that we need a new lexicon.
Because we've this very clunky
word of entrepreneur and made
it even clunkier by adding
all these qualifiers
from social entrepreneur to
mom-preneur to co-preneur.
And so I created the
zoology of entrepreneurs
and told stories around them.
The first to the gazelles.
These are the high growth
entrepreneurs from Google
to Home Depot to Jenny Craig.
Endeavor works
with the gazelles.
And that's a pretty known term.
I created a term called
the butterflies for people
who are formally mom and pop.
But I found today they need just
as many entrepreneurial skills,
even if you're starting
something in your kitchen
or in your basement,
you actually
need to know how
to get on the web
and how to get distributors,
or how to get on Shark Tank.
And then there's
the dolphins that
are the social entrepreneurs
or people also in government.
And I use dolphins
because they're
the most cooperative
and social animals.
But if you harm a dolphin's
pod or their environment,
watch out.
But my favorite animal species
in the zoo are the skunks.
And many of you are skunks.
This comes from Lockheed
Martin's Skunk Works program
that built fighter
jets in the 1950s.
But it's also because we need
people to stink up the joint.
And so one of my
favorite things that's
happened in the last eight weeks
since the book has been out
is people are coming saying,
I'm a skunk, I'm a skunk.
So that is one of my goals,
to breed more skunks.
So let me start with Get Going.
And I'm going to go through some
of the sections of the book,
and then I really want to open
it up to a lot of questions.
So it turns out that the
biggest barriers to getting
going are actually-- it's you.
And that everyone is looking
for permission from their spouse
or their parents or their boss,
and really what they need do
is give themselves permission.
And it's like what Bobby Jones
said about golf, that it's
a game played on a
five inch course,
the distance between your ears.
And I talk to a lot of people
about how they gave themselves
that permission to go forward.
And one of the things
that people had to do
is drown out the
noise around them.
So we all know
the phrase friends
don't let friends drive drunk.
Well, I've come to believe
that friends don't let
friends test drive their ideas.
And the reason is
that they're either
trying to tell you--
it's like taking them
to the last bridal fitting
and asking them to tell you
that your wedding
dress is anything
but perfect since there's
no time to change it.
Or they're so
nervous that you're
going to risk everything that
they're going to tell you
how terrible this idea was.
And they're not
reliable narrators.
And one of my favorite
stories in this regard
is the Banana Republic founders,
who are a courtroom sketch
artist and a photographer.
And they decide to
found this company.
And they want to create these
khaki uniforms like Safari,
but they also have
the cartoon artist
sketches out these
wonderful-- he calls himself
the minister of propaganda
and sketches out
these wonderful quirky letters.
And they're planning to use
this as the marketing tool.
And they go to a friend, they
take it off the printers,
and the friends look
at this and they say,
you can't send this out.
This is horrible.
Oh my god.
You left your jobs for this?
You're going bankrupt.
And they almost don't
send it out, but they do.
And years later when Banana
Republic cells to GAP,
it's mainly because of these
quirky letters they did it.
So they would never have gotten
it off the drawing board.
So friends don't let friends
test drive their ideas.
Once you give
yourself permission,
people have all of these reasons
why they can't move forward.
And many of them
revolve around risk.
And what I've come to
realize is that our attitude
about entrepreneurship
and risk is all wrong.
We talk about these
moonshots, and yet just
as many entrepreneurs
are minnovators.
They start with
mini innovations.
They're not risk
maximizers, they're
actually risk minimizers.
So first of all, we
think that companies
start with millions of dollars.
It turns out half
the Inc 500 companies
were founded with
$5,000 or less.
Crowdfunding makes
this even easier.
Second, we think
people go all in
and then they leave
their jobs immediately
and they risk everything.
Sara Blakely, when she
founded Spanx-- many
of us familiar
with her products--
she sold fax machines
for two years
while she was getting the
product up and running.
Phil Knight of Nike-- who's more
just to do it than Phil Knight?
He spent nearly a decade
doing other people's taxes.
He worked as an accountant while
someone else sold the shoes.
So people don't take big
risks, they start small.
And even inside
companies, what I realized
is people did not
go to the boss.
People did not create
these big business plans.
They stopped planning,
they started doing,
but they went stealth.
So when I looked at Pfizer
and AT&T and MTV and Clorox,
and looked at these
entrepreneurs, these skunks
within these companies, it
all fell through a pattern
that they basically realized
a need that needed fixing.
They go with their own
budgets or 10% of their time--
you guys have 20% time,
but most people don't.
And they started and they don't
get permission from the boss
until they have
the proof points.
So at Clorox, it
was these two moms
that created these
eco-friendly products.
And it was only after they
had a product line that they
went and told their boss.
It became Clorox
Green Works, which
was the first
innovation in Clorox
within 20 years in a major way.
So stop planning
and start doing.
Now, the second step of
entrepreneurship is going big.
But what happens
at that point is
that many people have
engines crash to the floor,
just as Henry Ford literally
had his prototype of the Model T
crash to smithereens before
he vowed to rebuild it.
And I actually
have a white board
of all the common mistakes
that entrepreneurs make
and how they can then scale-up.
But I want to focus
on two things today,
and then I'm happy
to answer questions--
chaos and leadership.
Because one thing that is common
for all entrepreneurs is you
hit this moment of chaos,
whether it's of your own making
or whether it's the
situation around you.
And what I've come
to realize working
in Egypt after the revolution,
in Miami after recession,
and Greece after its
financial crisis,
is that stability
favors the status quo,
but chaos favors
the entrepreneur.
Walt Disney actually started
with nothing in his pocket.
All his cartoons
were taken from him,
including Oswald the
Rabbit, which at that point
was his successful character.
It was stolen from him.
And in a rage on a
train, he drew a mouse
with red velvet
pants and buttons
that became Mickey Mouse.
And it was in his moment of
despair and the moment of chaos
that that creation was made,
and it's so emblematic.
And my favorite
story in the book
is actually a story of managing
chaos and managing risk.
And it takes place in the
1800s in Northeastern France
when a woman named Barbe Nicole
Ponsardin inherits a family
winery and is put in charge of
this business she knows nothing
about.
And she manages to
revolutionize it.
She takes the bottles and
turns them upside down,
freezes off the excess yeast,
and creates modern champagne
as we know it.
So her 1811 vintage is known
as the first modern champagne.
But just as Barbe Nicole
perfects the process,
the Russians invade.
And all the experienced wine
owners shutter their doors
to protect their vineyards.
Barbe Nicole spots a
marketing opportunity
and resolves to get the
Russian army wasted.
Today they drink, tomorrow
they will pay, she says.
And this works incredibly well.
And she makes one
more calculated risk,
which is before peace is
signed, she runs the blockades,
gets her bottles right outside
St Petersburg and Moscow
so that when the
treaty is signed,
her bottles arrive first
beating out the competition.
Czar Alexander declares he
will drink only the Widow.
Veuve is the French
word for widow,
and Barbe Nicole's late
husband was Francois Clicquot.
This is the story of
Clicquot, and it's
the story of how one woman
embraced the turbulence
around her and took
smart risks to become
the first female owner
of a multinational.
It's a great story.
So the last thing I want
to just briefly mention
before we go to questions
is I did a lot of digging
into leadership.
And this is really important
in the context of skunks,
because as I mentioned
before, all of these leaders
were saying I don't understand.
We talk about failure.
We talk about risk taking.
Why isn't it getting through?
And it turns out 40%
of managers today
say they won't take risks
because they fear retribution
if something goes wrong.
And I looked at, OK,
everyone talks about
and gives lip
service to failure.
What are companies
that actually really do
a good job at inculcating
this into the philosophy?
And two that came up-
one is the Tata Group.
So Ratan Tata runs the
largest conglomerate in India.
He actually just retired.
And in his last year
as chairman-- and he's
in his 70s-- he announces
a prize for the best failed
idea, which I think every
company in the world
should institute a prize
for the best failed idea.
The other story which
was really new to me
was the story of WD-40.
We all use this product
to get our squeaky doors.
Does anyone know how it started?
OK.
So in the 1950s, this
guy named Norm Larson
was trying to solve rust
in the aerospace industry.
And he tries one formula.
He figures it has to do
with water displacement.
First formula doesn't work,
second formula doesn't work.
39 formulas failed.
The 40th formula,
he gets it right.
He brings it to
General Dynamics.
And it works in the
missiles, but the workers
start sneaking it home
to fix those car doors.
And so Norm Larson's
like, wait a minute.
I got something here.
I'm going to create a
consumer facing company.
Looks to name the product, goes
back to his lab notes-- water
displacement 40th formula.
So failure is
inherent in the brand.
And today, the CEO says for
every decision in the company,
we are going to have
these learning moments.
We're going to talk
about what failed
and what went wrong in
addition to what went right.
So I think there are things
that you can actually
do to actually go from talking
about failure to embedding
this notion of risk taking.
I alsa-- again, while, I
love the moonshots idea,
I think for some people
that scares people off.
And I've come to believe
that minnovations,
these many innovations,
are almost as important
as the moonshot ideas.
And then we need to have both.
But the last thing I'll talk
about-- because it's the most
personal, it was the
hardest for me to learn--
was as a female
leader, I had always
thought that the job was to
be independent and strong and
confident and to separate your
family life from your business
life.
And this worked
well for a while,
then I had identical twins
and I was put on bed rest.
And so that went out the window.
But I was still
managing somewhat.
And then six years
ago, my husband Bruce
got diagnosed with a
rare case of bone cancer.
And we learned that he
was going to have to go
through a year of chemotherapy.
He would also have
a 16 hour surgery
to replace his entire
femur and to graft
the fibula onto the femur.
This had been performed
only twice before.
Our girls were
three at the time,
and this was right when
Endeavor had gotten $10 million
to double the rate
of our expansion.
And I was not
getting on a plane.
I was going to go to those
chemotherapy sessions
and make sure the
girls were stable.
And I told the board
and I told the team.
And what never surprised
me was that Endeavor
surpassed its growth targets
and that everyone stepped up.
But here's what did surprise me.
When I came back full
time-- Bruce I should say
is six years cancer free.
And when I came back to work,
two employees pulled me aside
and they said, you know
Linda, we always admired you
and we thought you
were superhuman.
And not in a good way.
This was in an unrelatable way.
And they said now that we
know who you are as a person,
now that we've seen
you be vulnerable,
now we'll follow you anywhere.
So the lesson for leaders
is less super, more human.
I'm going to end there that
the last section of the book
is go home.
I talk a lot about not
only work life integration,
but about creating
atmospheres where
people can do well and do good.
Millennia;s in particular have
really led the way, I think,
in showing why impact matters.
But I really would love to
open it up to all of you.
So thank you, and ready
to answer any questions.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: I just point
out that we have books for sale.
The hardcover books are on
sale for $10 in the back room.
So please, please have at it.
LINDA ROTTENBERG:
And I would like
to point out that I worked
every day with Tao Suarez
on this book.
He is now a Googler, but I just
want to personally thank him
for all his great work on "Crazy
is a Complement." [APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name's Lindsay.
LINDA ROTTENBERG: Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My dad's an entrepreneur--
LINDA ROTTENBERG: Yes.
AUDIENCE: He's an inventor,
for lack of a better term.
He's a chemical engineer, so
he has patents in his name.
And I've always
admired him quite a bit
for how he's able to build
something from nothing
over the last 30 years.
I have very
different skill sets.
And I think more about taking
ideas that are already existing
and making them a
little bit more fun,
interesting, more
age appropriate.
So I'd love to hear about
what types of businesses
you've worked with where it's
more about tweaking an existing
idea and making it better as
opposed to what my dad does--
literally thinking of things
no one has thought of before.
LINDA ROTTENBERG: That
is a great question.
And I think that
many of us grew up
thinking if we weren't
the inventor type,
then we weren't entrepreneurs.
We might be managers in
entrepreneural companies,
but we couldn't be
entrepreneurs ourself.
I've come to completely
change my view on this.
And in fact, at one point, we've
gotten to 1,000 entrepreneurs
at Endeavor.
And they were so
diverse not only
in the industries
they were working in
and their backgrounds,
but in their approaches
as leaders and their
strengths and weaknesses.
And yet they were all
trying to model themselves
after Steve Jobs.
And I was like, but
this isn't working.
You have different strengths
and different weaknesses.
So I worked with Bain &
Company for three years
on an entrepreneur
personality test.
It's really a personality
test as a leader.
You can go download it
at lindarottenberg.com,
a shortened version.
And what we realized, we came
up with four personality types.
These are different
from my species.
So the rocket ships
are people who
really care about
efficiency and metrics
and taking things that work
and making them even better.
The stars focus on brands
and they're more personality
driven, often more in the arts.
Transformers often take older
businesses and modernize them.
And they're really interested
in both the mission
of the new businesses, but how
you transform these old school
products and services.
And then the diamonds are more
of the classic inventor types.
And each of these
personalities, as I said,
has the ability to be the
leader and the entrepreneur,
but who you surround yourself
as a team, as advisors,
and as mentors does change.
So I would encourage you,
take this personality test.
We have a longer version if
you're really interested.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I guess my question is is
I think a lot of people
sit and they think of an idea,
and then they think oh, someone
probably has done this.
Someone probably knows
better about this.
Who am I to do this?
And I guess what
kind of advice do
you have for one getting a sense
if you should be doing that
to how to just go
through that process?
LINDA ROTTENBERG: The greatest
ideas, I've come to believe,
do not die in the marketplace
or in the laboratory
or in the conference room.
They die in the minds of the
people who have them and never
get them off the ground
for exactly that reason.
I think today more than ever
before with crowdsourcing
and crowdfunding, we have ways
to get early feedback that's
not from those
family and friends
earlier than ever before.
And so I really encourage
people to test that out.
Because I think that the
great thing about crowdfunding
and crowdsourcing is it's
not just about the money.
It's whether people
actually are motivated
to say I need that product,
I need that service.
And I think that with
social media even
using other social
networks, there's
ways to get that
instant feedback.
But what I would say is it
goes back to that permission.
And that the biggest barriers to
getting going-- it's not money,
it's not the
structural impediments.
It's people holding
themselves back.
And you'll find out
soon enough, it's
all about execution at the end.
And what I always say is
the marketplace tells you
soon enough, just don't hold
yourself back initially.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi Linda.
Thanks for coming.
So you talk about--
I mean, you've
met a lot of entrepreneurs
through Endeavor.
And I guess the question I
have is regarding survivorship
bias in terms of you see
a lot of entrepreneurs
who have essentially been
very successful, or at least
successful to some degree.
Do you ever think about in
terms of encouraging us all
to be entrepreneurial,
there's always that factor
that I feel like
sometimes we ignore.
And that's the doubt
in our minds, right?
That's what holds
us back sometimes.
And do you address
that in the book?
And your thoughts
about that in general.
LINDA ROTTENBERG: In
terms of only talking
about the success stories?
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
Yeah, yeah.
LINDA ROTTENBERG: Yeah.
I mean, I think
that's why I spend
so much time talking about
people hitting walls, talking
about whether it's the chaos
which often is external,
but sometimes is internal
with our own screw ups,
to this white board
of common mistakes
people have at that
scale-up moment
when they actually go flat
or actually start crashing.
One of the things that
we talk about a lot
are the mechanics of the deal or
the distribution or the demand.
I've seen oftentimes
it's actually
relationships between and among
founders that kill things.
I always say Endeavor 101 is
how to fire your mother-in-law
and still show up
for family dinner.
And talk about getting
start up pre-nups
when you start with
friends and family.
Things like to
that other question
where people don't
know themselves
and they don't properly
assess their own strengths
and weaknesses as
an entrepreneur,
and they don't
surround themselves
with the right people.
So I go very much into
detail of not only people
from unexpected
backgrounds to make them
more diverse and
relatable and accessible,
but also all of the
stumbling blocks
that entrepreneurship
is not just
this linear path to success.
We often are told that and it
seems like the instant rags
to riches.
I think more of us need
to talk about the problems
and the struggles.
And not only the
external struggles,
but the internal
emotional ones as well.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
LINDA ROTTENBERG: And
back to the question
about crowdfunding.
IBM and some other companies are
starting internal crowdfunding
platforms for skunks.
So people are actually getting
feedback-- so they all get $100
and they can actually
put their money
based on which of
their peers ideas
they actually think
will likely work best.
I love that idea too.
Just getting a
sense of will people
put their money
where their mouth
is to know which ideas tend
to have takeoff potential.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Thanks so much
for your comments, Linda.
I can't wait to read the book.
I was curious if you could
talk a little bit more
about the group of
guys in Argentina
I think that you said made
it through the first round
and you turned them down
because of perceived arrogance,
but then the second time
around something clicked there.
In the context of
your story about how
you approached that
other investor and said,
you're lucky I didn't
ask you for $10 million.
I'm asking you for $200,000.
Which could be
perceived as arrogant,
but it's really
confidence and believing
in yourself and those things.
But theres, I think
with all people,
maybe women
especially in business
and in the
entrepreneurial world,
there's a fine
line to walk there.
LINDA ROTTENBERG:
A great question,
and I will answer
it in two ways.
With the Globant
boys, they just seemed
to have had everything
figured out.
And we thought would
they even take advice?
I think that was
the question we had.
And I'm so proud of them.
And they say that it's a
defining moment-- there
were four founders--
they all four met,
they wept, and then
when they found out
they were rejected
the first time.
And they met and
they decided we're
going to go through
this process again.
And I will tell
you, in part because
of that story and the
success they've had,
but how impactful it was
to actually face rejection
and have to come back and
change their own approach, now
20% of the entrepreneurs
Endeavor selects are
rejected the first time and come
back, which is pretty amazing.
With regard to women,
so one of the things
I hear a lot is, well, people
have these connections.
When you go in Silicon Valley,
there's a sense only 8%
of female led companies
are venture backed.
And since we're not part of
the club, and what can we do?
And what I always
say is that there's
the dark arts of
entrepreneurship
that they don't teach
in business school.
And many people of
all genders use,
but I found particular
I used and some
of my favorite female
entrepreneurs used.
And I'll tell one story,
and it is of stalking.
Let me say, stalking is an
underrated start-up strategy.
And I used to trap people
in confined spaces.
But my favorite story is a woman
named Josephine Esther Mentzer.
And she grows up in a Hungarian
Jewish family in Queens.
And she grows up very poor,
but aspires to luxury.
So she sees a woman at a beauty
salon with this nice blouse
and says, where did
you get that blouse?
And the woman looks at her
and says, what does it matter?
You could never afford it.
And Estelle, as she's known,
Josephine, she gets so mad
and she says, I'm
going to have it all.
I'm going to have the luxury.
I'm going to have the art.
And she realizes that her uncle
John is this struggling chemist
who can't sell these products.
So she goes and
literally stalks people
outside of Salvation Army
meetings and in the elevators
and says that her all purpose
cream can solve their wrinkles.
They don't think
they have wrinkles,
but nonetheless she does this.
And she builds up a
nice little business,
but she does not want
to sell in drugstores.
She covets luxury.
She wants to sell at
Saks Fifth Avenue.
So she starts
stalking the buyer.
But he's like, I'm sorry.
There's this unknown
brand and you're
this unknown entrepreneur.
No way.
And she says, all right.
I've got to do two things,
I've got to get more strategic.
So first she changes her name.
So it was Josephine
Esther Mentzer.
She changes it to Estee and
takes her married name, Lauder.
And the next thing she does
is at the Waldorf Astoria,
there's this charity
luncheon and she gives away
these lipsticks in these
metallic sheaths, which are
this big step up from plastic.
And the women get one
free one and ask her
where they can buy another.
And she says, oh, why don't
you try Saks down the street?
And as the buyer
then says-- there
was a line that forms
from the Waldorf Astoria
all the way to
Saks Fifth Avenue.
And the next day,
he places an order.
So yes, stalking is
underrated start-up strategy.
AUDIENCE: Hi Linda.
Thank you for your talk and
thank you for that story.
Actually, my team
calls on Estee Lauder
and we actually want to try
and remind the Estee Lauder
business to be a little bit
more like the founder today,
because it's gotten so big.
So we're like, how can you
be a little bit more nimble
in today's world?
LINDA ROTTENBERG: You have
to go back to the founding.
AUDIENCE: The DNA of--right.
LINDA ROTTENBERG: In
fact, GE when it came out
of the financial crisis, they
went back to Thomas Edison
and said, we're
builders, not bankers.
Because GE Capital had become
such the face of the company.
They had to go back to
their founding days.
AUDIENCE: So it's
like staying true--
LINDA ROTTENBERG:
Good on you, exactly.
AUDIENCE: --to who you are
throughout the process.
A question about your
management style.
So the example you just
gave about your husband
when he was sick--
and thank goodness
that everything's great there.
That was clearly
a moment where you
had to say, OK, what's
super important to me,
and probably turn over the reins
of the business to other people
you trust.
What are other moments
in your experience
maybe after that in
the last six years
that you've had to also say not
just for significant moments,
but just in the
day to day to help
other leaders within your
organization stand up
and find their own voice
and their own ground?
LINDA ROTTENBERG: Yeah.
it's partly about giving
people a space to grow,
and partly knowing your own
strengths and weaknesses
and realizing that not everyone
is motivated like you are.
So I'm someone who-- I
don't care about titles.
I don't care about
vacation days.
I'm like, you get your work
done, it doesn't matter.
And I realized after a while,
it actually mattered to people.
There are people
who wanted rules.
I was like, you want rules?
Rules are meant to be broken.
But no, they wanted rules.
And our president,
Fernando Fabre--
I was very unsuccessful
in getting a COO
because I recruited
from Nike and Disney,
and I thought people wanted
more corporate people.
And it turns out
they wanted someone
who had the DNA of Endeavor.
And I ended up hiring
three years ago,
three and a half
years ago, the person
who is now our president,
Fernando Fabre, who
had been seven years our
managing director in Mexico.
And I noted that any
time anyone in the world
had a problem with
me, they went to him.
I was like, all right.
Let's just make this
official and why don't you
come be the COO.
He was like, I'm not
doing that failed title
with these two failed COOs.
You make me president,
and I'll move.
So el presidente
now sets the agenda.
And it's been so nice, and we
respect each other so well.
But having those
complementary skills,
there are some people who
really need the structure
that he wants.
There's some people
want-- and I'm
freed up to give the
love and the inspiration.
And I think it goes back to
knowing yourself and realizing
to get going, it's all
about you and your idea.
But to go big, it's
about co-creation.
And to go big, if it
remains all about you,
you're not getting very far.
AUDIENCE: So that
actually set me
up perfectly for the question
that I was going to ask.
Which is you do a brilliant
job demystifying that there
is a single archetype
of an entrepreneur,
and really breaking it down into
the different flavors of that.
And I think probably one of
the things that I experience
and I see talked about
and in talking to people
is it's a very sort
of solo archetype,
the original entrepreneur
is, that I'm doing it myself.
It's my idea.
I'm creating it on my own.
But you mentioned the concept
of surrounding yourself
with the right people that will
complement your skills, which
I think is really important.
And especially at
Google, we're so
fortunate to work amongst
brilliant, talented
individuals.
So I'm curious to get your
take on your own companies,
the Endeavor companies.
Have you experienced
people coming in
and, for lack of a better
word, hoarding the idea
and you sending them back and
saying listen, great idea,
but go surround yourself with
people who could make it happen
or to refine it.
LINDA ROTTENBERG: Yeah.
Entrepreneurship is
not a solo sport.
And I think not only
are there studies
that many of the most
successful companies
are run by pairs or trios
of founders, not just one.
I should say also the
two fastest growing group
starting businesses today
are baby boomers over 55
and actually women
are now starting
to launch companies at faster
rates than ever before.
So back to you don't need
to be a boy in a hoodie
to be an entrepreneur.
Here's the thing I will
end on because it's
so emblematic of what I've
learned at Endeavor, which
is not only in companies do
you need to surround yourself
with this group of people
that are the co-creators,
not only do you
need not just one
mentor, but a circle of
mentors, but the process
of entrepreneurship
itself, Endeavor
is now looking at
what makes cities
conducive to entrepreneurship.
And it is not top down
regulatory changes.
it is not creating incubators.
It is not creating VC firms.
It is successful entrepreneurs
mentoring, investing in,
and inspiring the
next generation.
So what we've done in Argentina,
in Istanbul, in Amman, Jordan,
now we just released yesterday
a tech map of New York,
are what happens when successful
entrepreneurs pay it froward.
And, in fact, you see
this incredible effect
of them going and angel
investing and mentoring.
And that's how
entrepreneurship breeds.
So one of the things
we're doing is
saying this is happening
very well in many places,
but mainly in tech and
mainly with the guys.
So back to the women question,
back to the non-tech question.
We're saying if
you're in retail,
if you're in food and beverage,
if you're women, if you're
an older person, do this.
Give back.
Spend part of your time
mentoring and angel investing,
because that's actually
the way that an ecosystem,
that a community of
entrepreneurs is created.
Thank you.
Thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]